depuis l'assassinât de samuel pâti en
octobre dernier la question du respect
de la laïcité à l'école fait
régulièrement débat
vous vous interrogez notamment sur les
moyens d'action pour la faire respecter
au sein des établissements scolaires
alors nous nous sommes posé cette
question que peuvent faire les profs
face les nattes heurte à la laïcité
des éléments de réponse dans facture
[Musique]
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'une atteinte à la
laïcité
d'après ce document de l'éducation
nationale les élèves n'ont pas le droit
de porter des signes religieux
ostentatoires comme le voile la kippa ou
encore une croix de trop grande taille
tourner les pages
il est aussi inscrit que ni les élèves
ni les parents n'ont le droit de
contester l'enseignement en raison de
leurs convictions religieuses
l'atteinte à la laïcité la plus courante
est le port de signes religieux
les refus d'activités scolaires et les
contestations de l'enseignement sont en
progression pour faire remonter ces
informations
voici le dispositif mis en place
attention accrochez vous c'est pas
simple un professeur peut en faire part
à son supérieur qui va le signaler dans
l'application fait établissements ou
sollicité l'équipe académique valeurs de
la république en fonction de la gravité
le signalement peut être prise en charge
par l'équipe académique valeurs de la
république
mais lorsque le fait plus grave il peut
être envoyée à l'équipe nationale
aiguillés par un conseil des sages et en
ultime recours
l'ouverture d'une cellule ministérielle
peut être décidée plus dispositif et est
très très cool et je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils
beaucoup d'enseignants qui sont encore
parce que ça induit c'est que ça suppose
y compris dans les médias qu'on est
confrontés quotidiennement à des
atteintes à la baisse selon l'enquêté
ifop pour l'observatoire des enseignants
64% des professeurs jugent que les
réponses sont adaptés tandis que 30%
jugent que la réaction est trop
complaisante mais alors que risque un
élève qui viendrait avec un signe
religieux ostentatoire par exemple cela
peut aller de la simple discussion avec
les personnes concernées jusqu'à
l'exclusion définitive de l'élève
en cas de non résolution du conflit même
chose pour un élève qui refuseraient de
se rendre en cours d'éducation civique
et morale par exemple en raison de sa
religion
les professeurs disposent d'ailleurs de
secours de m ces pourparlers et éduquer
sur ce qu'est la laïcité une meilleure
arme selon eux que le signalement
lorsque je mets en place un projet même
c'est un travail sur le longue haleine
sur la laïcité avec une casse pas déjà
c'est c'est mieux parce que je prends
les élèves au début de l'année à avant
qui est un problème
ce qui fait que les élèves ont confiance
en moi et on n'est pas dans la réaction
à un problème il ya plein de choses à
décanter sais c'est un travail de longue
haleine qui essayent de semer c'est que
cellou est à mon avis un dispositif qui
serait uniquement
voilà on va dénoncer ça et après et
après il n'y a pas de garantie pour
l'enseignant que l'élève change d'avis
pour eux si le fait n'est pas grave il
vaut mieux inciter les élèves à parler
pour le faire réfléchir sur ses pensées
mais c'est compliqué de dire les lèves
tu peux dire tout ce que tu veux mais
attention si tu dis vraiment ce que tu
penses c'est ce que tu penses c'est
c'est que
samuel pâtit l'avait bien cherché tu vas
être ça n'incite pas à des débats
sereins si les professeurs sont
aujourd'hui formés pour réagir face à
ces situations
ce n'était pas forcément le cas il y a
quelques années jusqu'à un événement
déclencheur mois ce qui a été pour moi
une bascule très forte et si les
attentats de 2001 d'abord autre charnier
doute on s'est dit que évidemment il
fallait s'emparer de cette question à
bras le corps il y avait tout ce qu'on
pouvait toutes les ressources qui était
à notre âne à disposition à cette époque
là j'ai des trous je me sentais fragile
par rapport à des questions d'élèves sur
et pour quoi on a droit de caricaturer
les sujets religieux et depuis ça va
beaucoup mieux au cours de leur carrière
53 % des enseignants ont déjà observé
une atteinte à la laïcité
les auteurs sont en majorité des élèves
devant les parents et les personnels
d'établissement
[Musique]
e